bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france à leurs véritables scènes
de violence à rotterdam on l'a vu en la
police anti-émeute a été déployée orgie
de violence ans selon les mots du maire
à quel point la situation est grave même
si le calme est revenu aujourd'hui on le
rappelle
oui il faut comprendre quelque chose qui
est très spécifique aux pays-bas depuis
le début de la crise les pays bas ont
adopté une politique très conciliante
avec la population ils ont même adopté
ce que l'on appelle comme concept de
confinement intelligent c'est à dire un
confinement qui fait confiance aux
néerlandais et qui n'est pas trop
restrictif et bien cet avis attitude
d'acceptation d'une certaine forme de
liberté les néerlandais sont en quelques
sortes de la payer ils ont connu une
inflation de 2 cas graves de covile et
ces cas graves il ne l'avait pas
vraiment prévu et c'est ça qu'il faut
comprendre les néerlandais surtout dans
les villes amsterdam rotterdam ils ont
l'habitude ils ont eu des attitudes
festive et interdire les rassemblements
à quelque chose d'insupportable
et c'est peut-être ce qui explique la
violence dans la mesure où on mark rutte
qui a été un petit peu débordé par
l'ensemble des arrivées dans les
hôpitaux et le débordement des hôpitaux
a été obligé de prendre des dispositions
beaucoup plus dur que d'habitude et
quelque part c'est cette surprise c'est
cette décision un petit peu dur et non
non anticipée par la population
elle-même qui peut-être a provoqué un
petit peu ce débordement de violence il
ya peut-être eu aussi une autre raison
c'est que finalement les hollandais ont
été un petit peu débordé aussi par une
augmentation due au fait que même si la
vaccination a été relativement important
sans que iba puisse y est à peu près
équivalente à celle de la france et bien
malgré ça effectivement les hollandais
ont connu une vague beaucoup plus
importante qu'ailleurs au plus
importante qu'en france notamment du
fait que les hollandais n'ont pas
véritablement respecter les gestes
barrières comme cela a été le cas dans
beaucoup d'autres pays
les hollandais ne portait pas le masque
sur unis c'est sans masque avait avait
se comporte et finalement comme le
combiné comme cisco vide était terminée
et bien c'est un petit peu ce laxisme
finalement que les hollandais sont
toujours obligés de payer ce qui a
peut-être provoqué aujourd'hui ce regain
de violence et est ce que mark rooney
est coincé parce que on se pose la
question comment le gouvernement va-t-il
mettre en place de nouvelles
restrictions s'il en a besoin pour
freiner l'épidémie si la population est
à ce point de la descente et bien c'est
une des figures l'est c'est une
difficulté réelle mark rutte n'avait pas
envisagé probablement sentir jusque là
il a été obligé de le faire du à la
violence et l'importance de l'épidémie
il va falloir maintenant qu'il arrive à
persuader les hollandais de la nécessité
d'avoir une discipline beaucoup plus
forte cela va être un petit peu
difficile mais bon si les hollandais
regarde bien ce qui se passe autour
d'eux et notamment en ce moment en
autriche où le gouvernement autrichien a
été jusqu'à finalement
provoquer un confinement général de
toute la population vaccinée et d'en
vacciner et bien finalement peut-être
ils espèrent que cela peut-être sera
fait réfléchir un petit peu les
manifestants qui rentreront dans le rang
mais c'est sûr aujourd'hui et sans voix
à peu près dans tous les pays d'europe
la dureté de la cinquième vague
d'épidémie provoquent de véritables
réaction des réactions extrêmement dure
et ses réactions est ce qu'elles vont
durer dans le temps on peut penser que
c'est relativement peu probable dans le
dieu de la gravité de la situation des
hôpitaux amènera peut-être la population
à plus de sagesse oui mais on voit en
guadeloupe en guadeloupe 1 on voit ce
qui se passe sur les leurs depuis le
début de la semaine c'est vrai que c'est
difficile de ne pas penser à la france
qui organisent des manifestations
cet après midi notamment contre les
restrictions sanitaires est-ce qu'on
peut comparer la situation des pays bas
à celle de la france sont et où on peut
la comparer en partie mais ça n'est pas
elle même travaillé sur ce ce que je
disais tout à l'heure contrairement à la
france les pays-bas n'ont pas
véritablement respecter les gestes
barrières et en particulier et dans la
période de l'été où ils ont considéré
évidemment que la pandémie était terminé
alors qu'en france il ya quand même de
transition peut-être siete même
surprenante les français globalement ont
respecté les gestes barrières les
français ont respecté ont accepté les
restrictions comme le pass sanitaires et
finalement cette espèce d'autres
disciplines des français finalement ne
se retrouvent pas au vivat c'est en ça
que finalement la situation n'est pas
comparable si on se regroupe c'est un
autre phénomène c'est la défiance quasi
généralisée des populations de
d'outre-mer finalement tout ce qui
pourrait venir des initiatives de la
métropole et donc la défense de ce que
pourrait apporter un vaccin schild est
obligatoire qui est considéré qu'une
certaine manière comme un espèce de
poisson et donc c'était un cas un petit
peu différent mais encore une fois la
france est dans une position
relativement favorable aujourd'hui mais
ça n'est pas ça n'est pas la fin de
l'histoire dans la mesure où on peut
estimer effectivement que 710 yens vague
elle progresse elle a commencé dans les
pays de l'est elle a commencé à l'est du
continent mais elle est en train de se
propager à l'ouest et la france n'est
pas à l'abri
françois pour les mathis merci d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes journaliste spécialiste des
institutions européennes marciac